FOR MONDAY MARCH NIGHT OF MY
CALL TO ORDER. PLEASE BE
ADVISED AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS P. MAINTENANCE ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. HAVE SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY.
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO FLORA
GRAYSON KAMLAGER HERE
MAIENSCHEIN THERE MATHIS WORKS
OVER HERE FROM OF SIR RIVAS.
WICKS WE HAVE. WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA. IS NO
TODAY'S HE FIVE HAS BEENADDED
TO THE LIST REFERRAL SAYS. THE
STAFF. IS OUR MOST ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA SOME OF WILL
RESTAURANTS CINEMAS QUIRK
SILVA- A MEASURE TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE.
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE CARILLO
FLORA. FLOOR I AGREE SENATE
RACE AND I KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I
MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE PERKS OVER I
WORK SO BY ROMANS FIVE FROM US
I RIVAS. THREE OF US I WEBSITE.
WORKS I. OKAY THAT MOST PLAN
AND I THINK YOU WERE. TENSIONS
ASSIST FROM.